i have so much i need to say hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be talking about rebel
wilson's weight loss diet but first let
me tell you about my sponsor billbar
friends if you have not hopped onto this
snack train get on it these bars are
really unlike any other protein bar i've
ever tried because they actually taste
like a candy bar so no chalky powdery
like mealy texture
nah plus there are so many fun flavors
so today
i always get so pumped
oh the green is catching my eye
matching
shall we we shall
yeah
mint
brownie
what
nothing like the smell of chocolate in
the morning
[Music]
17 grams of protein in this baby and you
know what i say about the zero guilt
thing unless you stole them from a baby
all foods are zero guilt these are one
of my go-to bedtime snacks or i use them
on top of my oatmeal to really bump up
the satiety factor and turn them into a
hunger crushing combo so if you want to
give these a try check out the link in
the description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your order
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are new here subscribe to this
channel ring that bell so you never miss
out and follow me over on tick tock and
instagram abby's kitchen so back in 2020
rebel wilson embarked on the
self-proclaimed year of health and has
since meet headline news for her 70
pound weight loss but it wouldn't be a
celebrity weight loss story without a
celebrity endorsed diet would it is that
right and in rebels case she credits the
mare method for helping her achieve her
weight loss goals i just want to pop in
here quick to say that i'm aware that
rebel wilson denied that she did the
meyer method to lose weight that's not
what this video is about i'm not
debating whether or not she specifically
engaged in the meyer method or whether
or not it was the reason or the catalyst
for her weight loss i'm really just
talking about the meyer method itself
and using this youtube video to kind of
debunk a lot of the myths so let's do it
so today we'll be diving into the
principles of the mayor method and
whether or not it's beneficial for
sustainable weight loss let's take a
look he's been following the mayor
method basically the mara method is just
a diet plan that focuses on improving
gut health starting kind of from the
inside out here is a list of foods that
you are allowed to have and here's a
list of foods that you are not allowed
to have so the mare method claims to
promote weight loss from the inside out
by targeting gut health and it takes a
two-pronged approach by focusing on
mindful eating practices and following
an alkaline diet to alter the body's ph
oh boy okay first things first our
body's ph is very tightly regulated so
no amount of alkaline foods are capable
of altering our body ph nor would we
wanted to because
we would die so despite the alkaline
diet being widely debunked this strange
quest for alkalinity prevails in the
world of pseudoscience and from that the
mare method has been bored
that's weird let's dive into the mere
methods diet rules coffee give me
strength
but wait there are in fact some diet
rules rule number one no snacking this
is basically used as a way to just
prevent insulin spikes throughout the
day have we not gone through this i feel
like i'm taking crazy pills so the fear
of spiking your insulin is often touted
as the rationale for why intermittent
fasting works but as i covered in my
video on intermittent fasting here and
insulin here insulin may be the fat
storage hormone on paper but it's not
going to store fat and therefore
contribute to meaningful weight gain
without a caloric surplus it's also
tightly regulated in the body in folks
without diabetes so
we can put that concern to bed now of
course there is something to be said for
how blood sugar and insulin spikes make
you feel and influence hunger a snack
that's straight up candy is going to
have a dramatically different outcome on
blood sugars compared to something that
has fiber protein and or fats and this
is the whole point of my hunger crushing
combo it helps to slow down the blood
sugar response stabilize energy levels
promote better digestion and keep you
fuller for longer ultimately the reason
for this absolute rule of no snacking is
less to do with insulin as the big bad
fat storage hormone and more to do just
with limiting your opportunities to
consume calories next rule number two
you must eat breakfast not only does the
mare method emphasize breakfast but they
also suggest that you must aim to eat
like a king for breakfast a queen for
lunch and a popper for dinner in other
words you should front load your
calories to earlier in the day and also
stop eating by 7 pm ah
and the law for starters we know that
eating breakfast can support weight loss
and that a high protein breakfast
specifically may help to regulate
appetite by essentially lowering the
hunger hormone ghrelin we even have some
research showing that folks who ate a
high protein breakfast ended up eating
about 135 fewer calories in the day i
also think that this rule makes much
more sense in the context of insulin
since we know that our sensitivity to
insulin is at its peak in the morning
and gradually declines throughout the
day in other words if we can align our
food intake during daylight hours when
our insulin sensitivity is at its peak
it can definitely benefit our metabolism
and glucose response this early time
restricted feeding is possibly the only
context when the insulin suppressing
powers of fasting gives you any kind of
significant leg up on weight loss
however do we need to stop eating at 7
pm on the dot well there are a few
things going on here for one if we
follow the logic of early time
restricted feeding we can see that the
research has these folks cutting off
their meals by like mid-afternoon
literally like 2pm and in combination
with a calorie deficit this will allow
the body to burn through its
carbohydrate stores and then tap into
fat stores pretty early on but the key
word here is the calorie deficit since
most people can't live a normal life
eating dinner at like 2 p.m the main
rationale for not snacking before bed is
less to do with fasting and insulin and
more to do with the fact that we
generally prefer to eat foods that are
higher calorie and lower in nutrition in
front of the tv before bed you know we
tend to reach for chips not carrots when
we netflix and chill but like actually
chill so giving yourself a definitive
rule of no snacking before bed basically
just eliminates that option so i'm not
saying that insulin doesn't play a role
it can and it does but the far greater
player here is the manipulation of
calories hard stop rule number three you
have to completely eliminate caffeine
from your diet and then you're supposed
to eliminate dairy sugar gluten and
processed foods like any other celebrity
wellness diet mere method has jumped on
the wellness wagon to essentially
demonize the common offenders in the
name of gut health in this case we're
talking dairy sugar gluten processed
foods and caffeine but do these foods
actually impact gut health in any kind
of meaningful negative way well if you
have an intolerance sensitivity or
allergy to gluten or dairy then sure
eliminating these foods may make your
gut feel a lot better but otherwise
you're really just narrowing down your
food options which in turn naturally may
reduce your calories most high calorie
foods fall into these categories so you
can see how these rules would just
naturally chip away at your daily intake
the problem with this is twofold one
cutting out food groups eliminates a lot
of foods that can actually provide gut
health benefits like the probiotics in
fermented dairy and the fiber in whole
grains not to mention these are
nutritious additions rich in hunger
crushing compounds that can make weight
loss a lot easier for a lot of folks as
for caffeine well it absolutely can
trigger gi symptoms in a lot of folks as
i outlined in my video here we also know
that it might help improve the presence
and metabolic activity of beneficial gut
bacteria one study even found that
caffeine consumers had higher levels of
anti-inflammatory gut bacteria and lower
levels of potentially harmful bacteria
so
cheers i will drink to that
bull for my coffee please so like most
diets these days this appeal to gut
health seems much more like calorie
restriction in disguise as for the sugar
and ultra processed foods we obviously
do know that an excessive amount can
negatively impact the gut microbiome and
because they're low in hunger crushing
compounds can ultimately lead to weight
gain over time but i don't believe we
need to completely cut these things out
doing so often just makes you want them
more it's not sustainable are you gonna
tell me that you're never gonna eat a
slice of birthday cake again or that
you're gonna swear off normal bread for
life when you have no medical problem
with gluten that is a set up for a binge
i would way rather focus on what we can
add to support our gut health and to
build these foods into hunger crushing
combos that satisfy rather than always
focusing on what we need to remove rule
number four absolutely no distractions
while you're eating your meals this
means that you can't use your phone you
can't watch tv you can't read a book
it's also highly encouraged that you
don't even talk or socialize while
you're eating we have now arrived at the
mindful eating piece of the mayor method
program and while i can get on board
with the no distractions aspect the no
talking or socializing rule is a bit
extreme and also not really conducive to
good holistic health eating and dining
with family and friends is a large part
of our social nature and there's even a
large body of evidence that shows that
socializing over food has positive
benefits for our emotional health plus
if you think about applying the strategy
to the context of everyday life what are
you expected to do in like work settings
family gatherings or social outings just
like refuse to speak or be spoken to if
there's a plate of food in front of you
that's [ __ ] up now we actually do have
research showing that reducing
distractions while eating may help to
promote weight loss by helping you tune
into your hunger and fullness cues as
for the relationship between mindful
eating and better digestion the mind and
gut are so intimately connected so
slowing down and being present with our
meal may help to improve our digestion
so in conclusion mindful eating yes
social isolation ah
i think we've had enough of that in the
pandemic so that is a no hard note for
me and last but not least and probably
the weirdest rule of them all is rule
number five you have to chew every
single bite at least 40 to 60 times
before you swallow oh boy trigger
warning ahead here they come
so we do know that it can take about 20
minutes or so for your stomach to tell
your brain that you're full so slowing
down your meals can help you hear those
satiety cues before you've over eaten we
also know that chewing your food
thoroughly may benefit our digestion but
chewing each piece of food 60 times
before swallowing that is like straight
up pro anna subreddit advice the hyper
fixation on counting your chews is
actually the opposite of mindful eating
because it would completely distract you
from the meal at hand and turn every
meal into this exhausting torture
exercise for your jaw this is nothing
more than yet another hack to get you to
eat less food nobody's got time for that
also can't have anything to drink with
my meal i can drink before and after a
meal but not during ah yes the classic
water dilutes digestive enzymes claim
let's go through this again enzymes do
not target water they target specific
nutrients so for example if a protein
enzyme does not detect a protein it will
not and cannot bind to something else so
if water is thrown into the mix it will
not bind to or dilute enzymes because it
simply does not have the binding
capacity to do so research has also
quickly disproven this theory so
drinking water with a meal may actually
help to improve digestion as it helps to
soften food particles allowing them to
travel more smoothly down the digestive
tract which may help to prevent bloating
and constipation let's put that one to
bed oh dear god not this again i thought
we laid this to rest like five years ago
okay according to the mirror method our
digestive system is at its optimal level
arbitrarily until 4 pm at which point we
should give our digestive system a break
by eating something cooked as if our gi
tract has like a straight eight-hour
shift so that's bs for one but the raw
food diet is also not ideal since
cooking food any time of day will help
to break down and soften the fibers of
plant-based foods and increase the
bioavailability of antioxidants like
beta-carotene lycopene and lutein one
study on tomatoes for example found that
cooking actually increased their
antioxidant capacity by over 60 percent
so it's actually a good thing to get a
mixture of raw and cooked foods in our
diet but again if we're really trying to
shine a light on gut health as mara
method claims to do it's worth noting
that many of the foods on the allowed
list are actually quite high fodmap
which may not be very gut friendly for
folks with sensitive guts which are
probably the kind of people who are
doing a diet like this plus if you abide
by the raw till 4 rule you're limiting
yourself even further to just raw fruit
veggies seeds and nuts because basically
anything other than these foods would be
unsafe or indigestible to consume
uncooked so not only is this going to be
hard on your gut but it's also going to
limit the nutrient and food diversity
that you're feeding your gut microbes
which we also know is probably the worst
thing for long-term gut health so again
this does very little to support gut
health and digestion it's just another
restrictive diet dressed up in more
gentle wellness buzzwords like gut
health and mindfulness but with all that
said
let's take a look at kayla's thoughts
after one week on the mare method the
final product of the salad i've got
spinach romaine apples onions walnuts
goat cheese and then chicken and i'm
gonna top it off with some oil and
vinegar because that is the dressing i'm
allowed to have just made some oatmeal i
mashed a banana into it so it would be
like there in every single bite added
some almond butter and then to the
oatmeal i also added cinnamon and
sugar-free vanilla
so i appreciate that kayla just said get
to the raw till 4 rule at least we have
like more diversity in the day and more
high quality protein options for
breakfast which as we discussed is
definitely advantageous i can't believe
i'm saying this but this past week
actually went very well whatever rebel
wilson is doing actually seems like a
very sustainable and realistic way to
diet or to just kind of eat better and
be the healthier version of yourself it
wasn't overly restrictive which is
something that i highly commend rebel
wilson for of course it does ask you to
kind of eliminate your sugar and your
gluten and your caffeine intake so if
we're strictly looking at the mare
method based on the foods that are on
the allowed versus not allowed list then
i guess you could argue that it isn't
overly restrictive to do at least for a
very short amount of time but this is
only the like what aspect of the diet as
i've just described it also puts
restrictions on when how how much how
it's prepared and also how many times
you have to
chew your food that's where i'm like no
way so let's summarize shall we does
this diet cause weight loss probably
because you've taken all the joy out of
food in your life and you've got so many
rules you'd probably eat very little
just to ease the mental burden of said
rules does this diet support gut health
not if you don't have an intolerance to
the foods that you're cutting out and
the limited diet variety may actually
result in worsening your gut health over
time does this diet promote mindfulness
only if your idea of mindfulness is
chewing raw food until your jaw seizes
and you enjoy eating in complete
isolation oh gosh
oh that's really bad but that's a real
real real cop-out interpretation of
mindful eating mindful eating is about
engaging the senses it's about pleasure
it's about observing the world around
you and taking it all in this sounds
more like doing everything you can to
convince yourself that you just like
don't like food i weighed myself on the
last day after following rubble's diet
for a full week and i ended up losing
three pounds nothing crazy but i did
overall feel really good this entire
week while following the diet i also
incorporated working out almost every
single day which is something i hadn't
been doing which definitely helped me
feel better this week really opened up
my eyes to how important it is to just
kind of be present and focus on your
meal i'm sorry are we shocked don't be
shocked you're shocked you're shocked
while kayla arguably did a kind of light
version of mirror method for a week it
makes sense that this would still likely
result in some weight loss considering
she's eliminated foods she's exercising
every day and putting in like so much
overtime to chew but i would also bet
that a lot of this is water weight not
fat loss from the very low carb intake
so what are my overall thoughts on rebel
wilson's mayor method diet well despite
its celebrity endorsement and hiding
behind trendy wellness terms like gut
health and mindfulness let's call a
spade a spade the mare method is a
restrictive diet that uses every sneaky
tool in the pseudoscience toolbox to
make you eat less and suck the pleasure
out of food its laundry list of rules
promotes the opposite of what it claims
to and long term may actually be
detrimental to our gut so while there
may be some merit to certain elements of
the mare method like prioritizing
breakfast limiting distractions at
mealtimes and being mindful of sugar and
ultra processed foods it's never going
to support a full well-nourished life so
on that note that's all that i have for
you guys today thank you again to
billbar for sponsoring if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who or what
you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]